When you're first building an
application, transactions are easy. You
have a database, and when a customer
places an order, you wrap the whole
thing in a transaction. Charge their
card, reserve the inventory, record a
ledger entry for accounting. If any of
those rights fails, the database rolls
everything back automatically, and it's
just like nothing happened. You probably
don't even think about it much. Your
database gives you what are called acid
guarantees, which basically means two
things that matter here. First,
atomicity. Either all three of those
rights happen together, or none of them
do. There's no world where the card gets
charged, but the inventory doesn't get
reserved. Second is isolation. While
that transaction is in progress, no
other part of your system can see the
half-finished state. Another query
checking the customer's balance won't
see a charge for an order that hasn't
fully processed yet. The database
handles all of this behind the scenes,
and you just write your SQL and move on.
But, when your application grows, you
start to get more traffic, more data,
more rights. And eventually, that single
database starts hitting its limits. So,
you do what everyone does at this point.
You split things up. Maybe you shard the
database to spread write load across
multiple machines, or maybe you break up
your monolith into microservices, where
each service now owns its own database.
The specifics can vary, but the result
is the same. Your data now lives on
multiple independent machines instead of
one. And at this point, everything
changes. The payment flow that used to
be one transaction against one database
is now three completely separate
operations against three separate
databases on three separate machines.
The card gets charged to the payment
database, inventory gets reserved in the
inventory database, and that ledger
entry gets recorded in the accounting
database.
You can't wrap a transaction across
these independent databases, because
they don't know about each other. So, if
the card charge commits, but then the
inventory reservation fails because the
item is out of stock, there's no
database-level rollback that can undo
that charge. It's already committed in a
completely different database on a
completely different machine. When
you're processing thousands of
transactions a second across distributed
infrastructure, partial failures like
these aren't edge cases, they actually
become pretty routine. Now, this whole
class of problem is what's called a
distributed transaction. A single
logical operation that needs to span
multiple independent databases or
services, where all the steps need to
either succeed together or be cleaned up
when something goes wrong. The textbooks
give us two approaches to distributed
transactions. Two-phase commit and the
Saga pattern. In practice, the industry
has overwhelmingly chosen one over the
other, and understanding why will save
you a lot of pain. The two-phase commit
is a classic academic solution to
distributed transactions. The idea is to
introduce a new component called a
coordinator, whose entire job is to make
sure that all participants in a
transaction agree on the outcome before
any make their changes permanent. It
works in two phases, which is where the
name comes from, of course. In the first
phase, called the prepare phase, the
coordinator sends a message to every
participant, asking, "Can you commit
this transaction?"
Each participating database then does
the actual work. It processes the
request, durably records the changes so
that nothing is lost if it crashes, and
locks the affected rows so that no other
transactions can modify them in the
meantime.
Then it responds to the coordinator with
either yes, I'm ready to commit, or no,
something went wrong.
If any single participant votes no, the
coordinator tells everyone to abort and
release their locks. If every
participant votes yes, on the other
hand, then the coordinator moves to
phase two. It sends a commit message to
everyone. Each participant makes its
changes permanent and releases those
locks, and the transaction is now
complete. What this gives you is strong
consistency, the same guarantee you had
with the single database. Every
participant agrees on the outcome before
anything is finalized. So, there's no
window where the system is in a partial
or inconsistent state. On paper, it's
exactly what you want. But, the problems
show up when you try to run this in
production. The fundamental problem with
two-phase commit or 2PC is that it's a
blocking protocol and blocking in a
distributed system is dangerous because
you're now dependent on multiple
machines all staying healthy at the same
time. I want you to picture this. The
coordinator collects all three yes votes
from the participants. But then it
crashes. Right there, after collecting
the votes but before it gets a chance to
send the commit decision.
Now the participants are all stuck.
They're all sitting there with locks
held on the rows they prepared and they
have no idea what to do next. They can't
go ahead and commit on their own because
maybe the coordinator was about to tell
them to abort. They can't abort on their
own either because maybe the coordinator
was about to tell them to commit and the
other participants already went through
with it. So they just wait. And every
other transaction in your system that
needs to touch any of those locked rows
is now blocked, too, waiting for the
locks that nobody can release. Crashes
aren't even the only problem with 2PC. A
single slow participant holds up the
entire transaction. So if the ledger
service, for example, were to take 10
seconds to respond to the prepared
message, the card service and the
inventory service are both just sitting
there with their locks held for those
full 10 seconds doing nothing. That
means the entire system moves at the
speed of the slowest participant. And if
a network partition means the
coordinator can't reach the participant
at all, there's no safe default. It
can't tell whether the message got
through or not. This is why almost
nobody uses two-phase commit across
services in productions. Pat Helland
wrote a really influential paper called
"Life Beyond Distributed Transactions".
In that paper he argues exactly this
point. Distributed transactions across
autonomous services don't work at
internet scale. The industry took this
lesson to heart.
2PC does exist in production, but only
inside distributed databases like Google
Spanner or Yugabyte DB, where the
coordinator and the participants are
tightly coupled within the same system.
This way the database handles the
complexity internally so that you as the
caller don't have to. But across
independent services with different
deployment schedules and different
failure characteristics, that's where it
all falls apart. So, what should you do
instead?
Well, when companies need to coordinate
work across multiple services, the saga
pattern is what they reach for. Uber,
Netflix, Amazon, DoorDash, they all use
this pattern in production. Sagas start
from a very different assumption than
2PC.
You don't actually need all or nothing
atomicity spanning multiple services.
You just need a way to eventually get to
a consistent state, even when things go
wrong along the way. Instead of
coordinating one big distributed
transaction with locks held across
services, you break the work into a
chain of independent local transactions.
So, each service does its piece of work
and commits to its own database on its
own terms. When something fails further
down the chain, there's no way to roll
back to earlier steps since they've
already been committed to that separate
database.
So, instead, you run what is called a
compensating action.
These are business level undos that
reverse the effects of what already
happened. So, a refund instead of a
rollback, a cancellation instead of an
abort.
Something needs to detect that failure
and trigger those compensations. And how
that works is a key design decision
we'll get into in just a moment. But,
the trade-off is that instead of getting
the strong consistency you get with 2PC,
saga gives you what's called eventual
consistency. The system might be
temporarily in an inconsistent state
while compensations are running.
A customer might briefly see a charge on
their card before the refund goes
through, but it always converges to a
correct state and nothing is blocked
while that convergence is happening.
Other transactions can keep flowing
normally that entire time. Now, there
are two ways to implement sagas and the
choice between them determines who's
responsible for detecting failures and
running compensations.
The first approach is called
choreography and it's the decentralized
option.
It uses a publish subscribe pattern
where each service broadcasts an event
when it finishes its work and any
interested service can pick it up and
react. So, the card service charges the
card and then publishes a card charged
event. The inventory service is
listening for that event. So, when it
arrives, it reserves the stock and
publishes an inventory reserved event.
The ledger service picks that up and
then records the entry. If something
fails, the failing service publishes a
failure event and the upstream services
react by running their own
compensations. This works well when you
have a simple flow with just two or
three steps. But, once you get to five
or six services all publishing and
reacting to each others events, figuring
out the current state of any given
transaction becomes really difficult.
Where exactly did it fail? Which
compensating actions have already run?
Did the refund actually go through?
Without a central place tracking all of
this, you end up digging through logs
across a dozen different services trying
to piece together what happened. The
second approach is called orchestration
and it's what most teams end up using
once they reach any serious scale.
Instead of services reacting to each
others events, you have a dedicated
orchestrator service that controls the
entire flow.
It tells each service what to do one
step at a time. Card service, charge the
card. It waits for confirmation.
Inventory service, reserve the stock.
Wait for confirmation. If something
fails, the orchestrator knows exactly
what steps failed and can run the right
compensating action in the right order.
Tools like Temporal, which was created
by the engineer behind Uber's Cadence
workflow engine, or AWS Step Functions,
are purpose-built for exactly this kind
of orchestration. It's what we use here
at Hello Intervu to coordinate our
payment and fulfillment flows and it's
the pattern we'd recommend that most
teams use. The important difference
between Saga orchestration and 2PC
coordinators is what happens when it
crashes. The orchestrator doesn't leave
locks dangling across your system. It's
durable. When it restarts, it reads its
own state from a database and it picks
up exactly where it left off. So, no
rows are locked in the meantime and no
other transactions are blocked during
that recovery period. Sagas solve the
blocking problem that makes 2PC
impractical, but they introduce a
different kind of complexity, the
compensating actions themselves.
The idea of just undo the previous step
sounds clean, but in practice it gets
pretty messy quickly.
Say the card charge went through and
committed, and then the inventory
reservation fails because the item is
out of stock.
The compensation is to issue a refund on
the card, but unlike a database
rollback, that refund is visible to the
customer. They see an actual charge show
up on their card, and then a few seconds
later they see a refund. Their bank
might even send them a push notification
for each one. It works correctly, but
it's not the invisible cleanup that a
database rollback gives you. And some
actions are genuinely hard to undo at
all. If one of the steps in your flow is
to send a confirmation email, you can't
unsend that email. If you fired a
webhook to a third-party payment system,
you can send a follow-up cancellation,
but you can't guarantee that they'll
process it in time or at all.
Each step in your saga needs a
well-defined compensating action, and
some of those compensations are
inherently imperfect. On top of that,
compensating actions can themselves
fail. What if the refund API is down
when you need to issue that refund? Now
you need retry logic for your
compensations. And if you're retrying a
refund, you need the operation to be
item potent, meaning it produces the
same result whether you run it once or
10 times, so that a retry doesn't
accidentally refund the customer twice.
You end up needing the same level of
reliability engineering for your failure
handling as you do for your happy paths.
Even with solid compensation logic in
place, there's one more failure mode
that catches teams off guard. When your
card service finishes charging the card,
it needs to do two things: save the
result to its own database, and publish
an event to a message broker so that the
next service in the chain knows it's
time to proceed. The problem is that
those are two completely separate rights
to two completely separate systems. This
is called the dual write problem.
If the database write succeeds but the
event publish fails, the next step in
your saga never gets triggered and the
whole flow stalls. If the event publish
is successfully, but the database write
fails, now downstream services are
reacting to something that didn't
actually happen in your database. You
can fix this with something called a
transactional outbox pattern.
Instead of writing to your database and
publishing an event as two separate
operations, you write both your data and
the outgoing event into the same
database via a single local transaction.
The event goes into a special outbox
table right alongside your regular data
write. So that either both commit or
neither do.
Then, a separate background process
watches the outbox table and publishes
those events to your message broker.
That background process can use change
data capture, which means it tails the
database's own transaction logs to pick
up new entries, or it can simply pull
the outbox table on a regular interval.
Before you reach for either of these
patterns, the first question ask
yourself is whether you actually need a
distributed transaction at all.
If you can design your service
boundaries so that the data that
transacts together lives in the same
database, do that. This is easier to get
right up front than to try to retrofit
later. So it's worth thinking about
early. For example, move the inventory
and ledger table into the same database
that has the payments table if they
always need to be updated together. This
way a local database transaction is
simpler, faster, and more reliable than
any distributed alternative. And this is
always the best answer when you can make
it work. If you genuinely can't avoid
distributing the transaction across
services, you're going to use a saga.
That's not really a debate in the
industry anymore. The question is which
flavor of saga makes sense for your
situation. Choreography is usually where
teams start, and for simple flows it
works great. If you have three or four
steps, the services are truly
independent, and you don't need
centralized visibility into where each
transaction stands, choreography keeps
things simple.
Something like an e-commerce
notification system where an order is
placed event triggers an email or a
notification independently, this is a
natural fit. Most teams eventually
outgrow it as their flows get more
complex, but there's no reason to
over-engineer from day one. For anything
more complex than that, orchestration is
the way to go. Complex flows with
branching logic, flows where you need to
see exactly where a transaction is
stuck, flows where the compensation
logic is tricky and you want it defined
in one clear place rather than scattered
across half a dozen services,
most teams end up here and tools like
Temporal or AWS Step Functions make it
very practical to implement. One last
note, if eventual consistency truly is
not acceptable for a particular piece of
your system, consider whether that data
can live in a single distributed
database like Spanner or Yugabyte DB
that handle that strong consistency
internally for you. That's a very
different thing from trying to build 2PC
yourself across independent services. At
the end of the day, the pattern that
you'll see at most companies operating
at scale is Saga with orchestration,
independent operations at every step so
the retries are always safe, and a
transactional outbox to make sure events
are as reliable as database writes. It
means accepting eventual consistency,
but that's a trade-off the industry has
made deliberately. And it's the
architecture that Uber, Netflix, and
Amazon actually run in production today.